o tengo familia allí,
sino por la niña rural que vive dentro de este rostro brillante de fabulosidad.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Invité al público de Motswana a la historia, mi historia,
como persona transgénero hace años, en inglés, por supuesto,
porque la lengua suana es de género neutral
y lo más cerca que nos encontramos es una aproximación de "transgénero".
Y una parte importante de mi historia quedó fuera de esa historia,
por asociación y no por cualquier acto de vergüenza.
"Kat" fue una superestrella internacional,
una escritora de moda y estilo de vida, una música, productora de teatro
e intérprete...
todas las cosas que me califican para ser un ícono, emblanquecida,
'queer' de nueva generación digerible.
Kat.
Kat tenía un grado de una de las mejores universidades de África,
oh no, del mundo.
Por asociación, lo que Kat no era
era como los niños pequeños de piel morena
retozando por las calles de algún asentamiento ferroviario incidental
como Tati Siding,
o un pueblo fuera de la red como Kgagodi,
piernas vestidas con medias de polvo cuyas rodillas se habían ennegrecido
de años de arrodillarse y pulir pisos con cera,
cuyas espinillas fueron marcadas con lecciones de trepar a los árboles,
quién jugó hasta el anochecer
entró a cenar con una lámpara de parafina
y volvió a jugar a las escondidas entre ciempiés y búhos
hasta que finalmente la madre de alguien terminaría todo.
Eso se perdió tanto en la traducción como en la transición,
y cuando me di cuenta de esto,
decidí que era hora de comenzar a construir puentes entre mis propios.
Para mí y para que otros me accedan,
tenía que empezar a indigenizar mi rareza.
Lo que quiero decir con indigenizar es quitar la película de la vida de la ciudad
eso te impide ver a la aldeana dentro.
En un momento donde ser marrón, 'queer', africana y visto como digno de espacio
significa ser todo menos rural,
me temo que estamos borrando las luchas
eso nos llevó a donde estamos ahora.
La primera vez que salí "queer" en un pueblo,
tenía veintitantos años y vestía un kaftan.
Me ridiculizaron algunos de mi familia y extraños por llevar vestido.
Mi defensa contra sus comentarios fue la predeterminada
que nosotros, los que no tenemos un sitio,
los que somos mejores, se les enseña,
a encogernos de hombros y decir: "Simplemente no saben lo suficiente".
Y, por supuesto, estaba equivocada, porque mi idea de la riqueza del conocimiento
se basó en alejarse del pensamiento y la vida del Tercer Mundo.
Pero me llevó un tiempo darme cuenta de que mis actos de orgullo
no estaban más vivos en las ciudades globales que atravesé,
sino en las aldeas donde hablo los idiomas y juego
y me siento como en casa y puedo decir,
"He visto el mundo,
y sé que las personas como yo no estamos solos aquí, estamos en todas partes".
Y entonces utilicé estas casas de pueblo para la autorreflexión
y dar esperanza a otros que no tienen su sitio.
Indigenizando mi 'queeridad'
significa unir las muchas partes excepcionales de mí misma.
Significa honrar el hecho
de que mi lengua puede contorsionarse para hablar las lenguas romances
sin negar o hacer exótico el hecho de que cuando me muevo, puede hacer esto:
(Ululante)
Significa...
(Aclamaciones)
(Aplausos)
Significa marcar el ganado con mi madre o cortar leña con mis primos
no me hace menos fabulosa o rara.
a pesar de que ahora estoy acostumbrada a fiestas en la azotea, menús con vino
y salones VIP.
(Risas)
Significa llevar mi orgullo a través de la lengua de mi abuela,
la comida de mi madre, la canción de mi abuelo,
mi piel grabada con historias de caídas de burros
y años, años y años de dormir bajo un manto de estrellas.
Si hay un lugar al que no pertenezco,
está en una mente donde mi historia comienza con la rama de mí siendo 'queer'
y no con mis raíces rurales
Indigenizar mi 'queer' significa entender
que lo rural es parte de mí, y yo soy una parte indeleble de eso.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)